my guest tonight is a comedian who's
been seen in jordan peel psychological
thriller get out
as well as start in his own fox sitcom
now you can see him starring in the
much talked about netflix movie
everyone's discussing this movie
bad trip take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
wait a minute go get some butter
[Music]
please welcome lil rel howery
looks disgusting
[Laughter]
i actually i couldn't see what the clip
was oh my gosh
not pointed towards you it is it's first
of all i have so many questions which is
uh
clearly those women are not in on it
which is great they don't know what's
happening
i have to give it to him that first
woman she
opens the porta potty and then she's
actively trying to help you
never questioning how is it you're
sinking
well below the floor level of a porta
potty
i mean that made me that reaffirmed that
moment in the movie reaffirms my
my faith in humanity like these women
are just like being so nice
well that's the thing about it what
y'all don't realize is the way it's
edited
it just looks like i'll run into the
party party from the car yeah those are
actually
prank dates yes so bud malone was on
dates with these women yeah he was
uh no but even given that
yes you're on dates with these women and
you don't see that
but what happens is then you go to use
the porta potty
now still even if you're on a date my
wife
wouldn't open the porta potty and if i
was in that situation she wouldn't try
and pull me out
that was impressive i'm still yes you're
on a date and you have some relationship
with them
but i think that shows a lot of class on
their part and bravery i think they were
really classy for that
and also too like i was really disgusted
in it like i remember like
when they yelled cut and we were done
with the prank and everybody all those
throw up sounds she was doing was great
acting i'm like those wedding
sounds i was really it felt like it felt
so disgusting i don't care how much they
cleaned that porta potty yeah
it's still a porta potty yes it has
probably previously been used
and uh they're like no no we cleaned it
it hasn't been used in 20 minutes
you're good to go in there even if they
tell you it's a brand new one straight
out of the factory
that's the prop guy telling you who
might have just been like yeah just tell
him that
yeah just talented yeah yeah i mean
that's the other thing is you
were asked to do a lot i'm told
that you almost quit after the first
scene no matter almost the first
prank first thing we shot i quit okay i
walked off set i still had cause that's
when we had the
you know let's let's describe what
happened for anyone who hasn't seen the
film yet
this is so
stupid and so wrong
uh why don't you set it up why don't you
see what you tell us well
uh i don't even know how we can say it
over here but
uh our male uh it's the penis the
penises was attached
through a chinese finger trap me and
eric's penis yes okay
here we go what you did is you and uh
eric andre
uh you pretended that you were guys who
somehow got your penises
caught in a uh what's known as a chinese
finger trap
i believe and then you ask strangers
for help and um here you guys
are and this guy on the golf course now
those ladies that we saw earlier
reaffirm my faith in humanity
no one here wanted to help you and
people were mad people were so like
that's the one prank that made everybody
so mad like we were i mean we was
walking down the street because we did a
couple days we were just literally
just walking down the street without
painting strap these two homeless dudes
walked past like yeah they better not
say nothing to me
but they penises attack say say
something to me nasty mother
there's children on the street it's
disgusting how y'all do that
cause i know they better not say nothing
to me
[Laughter]
so okay so you t you you shoot that
scene
they yell cut and you said i quit i'm
not gonna do this well it was when
the first the first one we went into a
barber shop and they led us into the
wrong barbershop our security wasn't
there wasn't any cameras in there
i don't know what this brother was
talking about it felt like this man was
having a conversation with somebody let
somebody walk in here
with their penises attached to see what
i do because he was so angry
yeah we walked there very humble excuse
me sir he's like hey man what y'all
doing mike you started looking for a gun
he couldn't find it
okay and then he grabbed a knife chased
us out the shot
like this with rage on his face i break
out the trap
you know say i fall under a car we got
the wesley snipe security guard we had
did some crazy
whatever he did under armor and uh
man i quit i literally kept my costume
on and walked to the hotel
so i still had to trap on which was even
more weird that's great so you said i
quit
then you started watching walking back
to your hotel with your penis
stuck in a in a finger trap headed back
to the hotel yeah yeah i was
i was it was even crazy i remember
walking in it was like everybody in the
lobby was like
oh my god
and it's not a faker trap so we got a
police
uh but no i did and i called tiffany
tiffany i was like man eric almost got
me killed
i called my agents and everybody i'm
done with this i'm not doing this movie
i am an actor i've never called myself
an actor before i'm like
no i'm an actor man i'm not i'm not i'm
not johnny knoxville this is this is
insane to me
right and i called tiffany tiffany
really kind of convinced me not to quit
but then she thought it was really funny
and that irritated me too so i'll talk
to you later
and then she called eric and said eric
yo did you almost get little real kill
and she was like
he was like oh yeah i feel so bad she's
like please let
i need to be in this movie i love that
type of stuff and that's actually how
she got
that's great so you called tiffany
haddish
for for compassion as a friend to say i
want to quit this movie
she thought it was so funny that she
said i want in on this movie
yeah okay that didn't go the way you
wanted it i was so mad
like you ever like cause she was
laughing i was i was dead serious and
she just cracking up like you know some
how about i get off this phone with you
you know because i was too angry but i
wanted somebody to be like
he was wrong but she to say was wrong
she was excited about she like this is
going to be great i'm like
all right there's tons of funny stuff in
the film there's some stuff that got cut
because it didn't quite go the way you
wanted it to
there's a hitchhiking scene uh you and
eric are driving around
in this car is that right is this
correct i feel like i'm this is a trial
that's what it feels like yeah it does
look like sir is this correct you were
writing groundedness
in this what's that crown victoria
yeah and it's it's pink and it says bad
[ __ ] on the back
[Laughter]
sir tell us what what you and mr andre
were doing in this car
uh the prank was to pick up a hitchhiker
and chris rock played a
police officer that would pull us over
and question everything but
now here's the problem chris rock
is one of the most famous comedians in
the world
so the person who was not in on it
immediately recognized chris ross right
away i mean once again
chris rock didn't change his voice he
didn't want to put a mustache on or do
nothing he just chris rocked it like
it's like
okay like i don't know how people not
gonna know it's not chris rock but he
was i mean he did
how you know he did the i'm like bro
they know what you feel
yeah and you're right that's what chris
brock does in all his movies too
he's chris rocking it you know if chris
rock is in
hamlet he's not doing handling he's
doing chris rock
you know so
so the person right away was like you're
chris rock and the whole thing is
done but it made it what made it but
what made it funny though not
outside the prank is that people did
know it was chris ross and they were
just entertained by watching chris rock
do crazy stuff
yeah chris rockets shoot at the police
car chris rock is beating up eric and
there's people like man chris rocket is
crazy
yeah it just looked like it was a bunch
of lunatics and chris rock is crazy
you know i want to ask you about
something that everyone's been thinking
about these days which is
we are more than a year into this
pandemic looks like we're coming out the
other side
knock wood and everything's going to be
uh
i think much better but
everybody in our business who performs
for a living
in front of an audience we've all been
thinking
when when can we get back to performing
again and what's it going to be like
when we get in front of an
audience you very recently figured out a
way to go
on stage where was this was this in
tennessee it was in nashville yeah it
was in nashville
and you recorded a stand-up set in front
of an audience
and this was just how long ago like a
couple weeks ago a couple weeks ago yeah
yeah and first of all uh
that had to be very strange after not
being in front of an audience
for over a year to suddenly be back was
that scary were you afraid
well i wasn't nervous about that
until right before my intro but
because i was like dude why would you
record a combi album you ain't been up
in a year and a half are you crazy
but at the same time i've done sets like
you know if say finished i was shooting
a movie for a while and i go back on the
road
those first sets would be so like my
favorite sets
because i'm just i'm just going i'm just
whatever's on my mind it's
it's usually very raw and what it and
this is why i think honestly it's
probably my best work
actually that i've ever recorded um but
it was it was
it was a little nervous just being in
front of people yeah but then at the
same time like i
wore like i've wore a suit i've never
purposely wore a suit on stage before
in my whole career for on purpose and to
actually like you know someone throw a
suit on and
the audience energy was it felt like
they were just so happy
to be entertained again i think tommy's
going to be great for us coming
back that's what i'm kind of hoping for
and i think could be really nice is i
keep thinking
there could be a really nice moment
coming in
comedy music theater across the board
anything where there's an audience
because i think people are so hungry for
it
that i imagine you coming out and doing
a show you always get laughs but then
there's going to be this added energy of
oh my god we get to be in an audience
again
and that's got to be nice to feel that
love that love
and that com like and i've said this on
stage too i'm like yo
y'all actually are my friends at this
point because i haven't talked to nobody
for real and personally about any of the
stuff i'm talking about
right so it's like y'all basically are
my friends now and that's what it felt
like it felt like
a audience full of people because people
just haven't been around each other and
yeah comedy is going to be a very cause
i think now people
if they're going to pay to do anything
or leave the house they're like no i
better be entertained
like you're not going to be going to a
club just to be standing around looking
at people you're going to like want to
go somewhere
where you're actually entertained and i
think comedy
because we actually you know we make a
lot of these subjects comfortable
yeah and i think that's the ex i'm
telling you the audience was
so good and i just did an hour and a
half i'm just like
i felt like i blacked out on stage and
just went there and then when i listened
to it again recently because i'm doing
all the editing and stuff now it's like
yo this is this is probably my best work
but it's really honest
when can we uh when can we hear that
comedy out i think i'm gonna probably
release it after
either in between free guy which comes
out august 13th
and another film on man but i guess i
can't tell nobody
yeah let me ask you about this other
film you're not allowed to talk about
because that's my job
space jam sequel yeah okay
you're not allowed to say anything about
this but
um i know that you're somehow involved
am i allowed to say that
okay people are very excited
sir don't make me take my exhibits out
again
sure this is not you in the car i have a
photograph of you
are you in fact a bad [ __ ]
damn right i am so you can't
that must be frustrating i'm just going
to say you don't have to say anything i
think it'd be very frustrating
let's say you were in the space jam
sequel i'm not saying you are
but let's say you were and people are so
excited about that and you're not
allowed to tell people about it
i'd be going crazy i mean if
by chance i'm in that particular film
yeah
it's it is weird to not be able to be
like you know seeing the trailer do well
and all this stuff and you can't be like
i'm a part of that but allegedly if i
was a part of if you were a part of part
of it yeah
if you were particularly frustrated i
guess there's no way we'll ever know
if you're part of this like it's not
coming out july
bad trip is now streaming on netflix and
little rel may or may not
be in the upcoming space jam sequel will
never
ever know uh i i loved always talking to
you and then the fact that you came in
here in person
made it so much fun this was great man
it's just like you know see
andy and mr drummond
you know mr drummond normally doesn't
like to show but he heard you were here
and all four of kevin hart's decided to
show up which is very rare
um you got a really good packed packed
house here
i mean mr drummond being here it's just
it's the most
weirdest surreal thing to ever look at
like yeah
that came from i believe that's left
over from the tour
and so we used that and then just stuck
it in the back
backstage at our theater and then when
we needed cardboard cutouts we just
someone grabbed it and said well we've
got
four kevin hart's yeah and we've got mr
drummond so let's jam him in there with
all the real fans i mean that outfit
still works
today yeah god bless him god bless him
god bless him he's no longer with us you
know yeah no
he's moved on yeah but he's wearing that
outfit somewhere
right now mr drummond mr drummond
all right hey thank you why did we get
something
like a joke you started it you said oh
there's mr trump
and i follow you you're the master i
follow you don't
blame this song to come over to picture
now yeah it should all go to black
and then instead of his real name conrad
bain it should say mr drummond
1926 to 2016.